>> BIDELMAN: All right, so people are still
sort of filtering in but we can get started.
Thank you for coming. This is, What is a Web
App, and it's going to introduce you to the
Chrome Web Store and building an application
for the Chrome Web Store, so hopefully, you're
in the right place. Just a little bit about
myself for those that haven't seen me present
today. I--my name is Eric Bidelman. That's
my Twitter handle there @ebidel at the top.
I'm a developer programs engineer at Google.
I've worked on a bunch of different APIs and
helped their developers with Google Docs and
Sites and Base and OAuth. And now, I'm doing
things with Chrome and HTML5 and evangelizing
the open Web and all the cool stuff you can
do with Chrome and modern browsers. So, today,
we're going to talk a little bit about Chrome;
what is it, where we--where were we, where
we're at now. And also in regards to HTML5,
what's going on in HTML5 space in Chrome because
ultimately, you know, we're building Web apps,
we're going to be building them using technologies
like HTML5. And then we'll switch gears and
sort of think and talk about what a Web app
looks like. So thinking gets your mind thinking
about the certain components of a Web app
and how they look, how they feel. We'll talk
about the Chrome Web Store, how do you publish
an application, how do you write an app and
write or install the Web application. That's
kind of a new concept. There's two types;
there's a host app and a package app. I'll
discuss both compatibility and then we'll
take questions if we have time. So let's jump
right into HTML5 and Chrome. So you saw some
of this in the keynote but I just want to
reiterate it, why Chrome as sort of a developer
platform? Well, here's a--here's an interesting
graph. So you can see the initial beta of
Chrome all the way down to Chrome 9. And this
is a benchmark of the V8 JavaScript engine
that Chrome runs. This is the--the version
five of that benchmark. But you can tell that
the--obviously, the bigger bars mean better
and better performance. So over the last releases,
I mean, we just keep getting faster and faster
and faster. This is why applications like
Gmail and these big JavaScript-heavy and JavaScript-centric
applications work and work really well. Chrome
has 70 million plus active users. That's something
we announced at Google I/O. And that number
is only getting bigger. So if you're targeting
Chrome, if you're targeting it for the Web
Store, you have a huge potential user base
to reach. Stable channel update happen every
six weeks. So, we are iterating on this thing
lighting fast. And it's really nice that all
browser vendors now are competing. You have
Safari, you have Firefox, you have IE9 and
Chrome sort of driving the Web forward and
building these HTML5 APIs at lightning speeds.
You have new Canary build on Windows that
you can download. It's nightly build of Chrome
that you can test the latest and greatest,
the bleeding edge features, as they come out.
I mentioned 400% JavaScript performance improvement.
So just a--it's a really exciting space to
be in. So why HTML5? Well, you've seen a lot
of cool demos today. I did some of the keynote.
We've talked about them a little bit. I'll
just sort of break up this talk a little bit.
I'm going to switch to this mic and just show
you a few cool demos throughout the entire
thing. This is one I actually found today.
So, this is using the Drag and Drop API that
we demoed in the keynote but this one's a
little different. So let me find a nice image
to drop on here. I'll do the Chrome logo.
So this image data was read using the File
Reader API in JavaScript and you can tell,
you know, it's the Chrome logo. It's all pixilated.
But the really cool thing about this is that
it's using Canvas and it's breaking this image
pixel data up because you can read the pixel
level. And so, I can create a nice 3D cool
aspect of the--of the Chrome logo as I traverse
around. Really kind of cool. He's also incorporated
the device orientation API. So here's another
example where I move the computer and it turns.
Pretty neat. All right. So, that's why Chrome,
why HTML5. Now, why the Web? Why would you
want, if you're a desktop application software
developer, why would you want to switch to
the Web? Well, I think there's really three
key reasons. The first one, there's--I mean,
it's got--and maybe it's not obvious, I don't
know. But the zero installment, right, you
can access your application--your users can
access your application from anywhere and
anytime on the Web; there's zero install.
There's no friction in that. You know, they
get the latest security updates and features
that you roll out. When you click "deploy,"
they get the latest and greatest every time.
It's a seamless update. Cross-platform and
device support; this one, you know, this one
might be obvious, too. But obviously HTML5
is an emerging technology and it's still being
built up by the various browsers. But in the
long term here, everyone's going to support
it. It's going to be used across multiple
platforms, maybe for the term right ones and
run anywhere. Well, that's sort of the idea
behind, you know, the Web. But it's really
not just Chrome and the desktop, right? There's
different spaces. There's things like Android
and the smartphones that support HTML5 and
these web technologies. There's also a new
product, Google TV, right, that launched which
has Chrome built into it and a modern browser
that can run these cool technologies. So,
you're running your apps not only on small
device but, say, a 40-inch screen. So it's
a very different type of application environment
that you're used to. And, of course, those
two products, in particular, share WebKit
as the rendering engine. So you know if it
works, say, in Safari. It's probably going
to work in Chrome, Google TV, and Android
as well. So, what does a Web app look like?
I mean, we've talked about sort of applications
on the Web. I think you guys kind of know.
We use these everyday but here are sort of
my ideas of what a good, solid Web application,
at least the kind that we're looking for for
the Store, I have. So, one, it's goal-oriented.
It should be very task-driven. You go there
to serve a purpose and you maybe do--maybe
it's a music player app and you're searching
for music or you're playing music. It's very
task-driven and focused. The UI is tight.
It's beautiful and immersive. So, again, I
think, you know, as engineers we often get
in this niche where we're not the best designers,
I would say, but if you hire a designer, I
guarantee you're going to have more traffic.
CSS3, you know, the graphical capabilities
in the HTML5 now are amazing. And so, you
can really make a beautiful and immersive
site that sort of takes up the whole browser
space or whole rendering space on whatever
device you're on. You should sort of get lost
in the UI. It shouldn't feel--it should feel
like a native app basically. And in that regard,
it should have a rich user experience. Lastly,
it should be fast. I showed you the JavaScript
performance graphs earlier. But there's also
APIs that we talked about in some prior sessions
that really make this stuff lightning fast;
things like Offline, things like Web Workers
and Web Sockets for real time communication.
So, it should feel native but it's on the
Web. So now let me show you what I'm talking
about.
This is a Web site. And I won't go to these
sites, but this is--this will sort of give
you sort of a general idea of what some of
these--what a Web app, in my opinion, looks
like. So here's an example from the Associated
Press. It--you go there for a reason. You
go there to read news articles. It's fully
immersive. It's thinking about into things
like rounding corners and all the cool stuff
you can do in CSS. Another great example of
a music player, Twitter app. I mean, this
look and feel like native, say, iPad apps
or iPhone apps but they're Web apps. This
one's really simple. I mentioned focus-driven
and very goal-oriented. You know, everytimezone.com,
the whole purpose of the site is just to go
there if you forgot what time zone you're
in and how it translates to other time zones.
But it's using things like SVG and Canvas
to present a really cool user interface. So
you get the idea, right? These are--these
are Web apps but they look native and they
feel native. All right, I promised awesome
demos to get you guys excited so here's the
second awesome demo. Actually, I need Firefox
for this. So, Firefox, there's a new API in
HTML5, it's the audio data API. And what that
allows you to do is actually read data, say,
from an MP3 file as you're going to see in
a second, and you can process that data and
do anything with it you want. So you get the
raw byte information from the data stream.
You can also create audio on the fly using
this API. So here's an example of using HTML5
audio. This is the audio tag and this is what
it looks like rendered in Firefox and Canvas
to play an MP3 file. But at the same time,
it's rendering the spectrum of that sound.
It's doing this on the fly in JavaScript in
real time and it looks fantastic, right? I
mean, there's no lag here whatsoever. I could
play it all day, but I won't. Here's just
another quick example of the auto data API.
This is also in Canvas. Is my sound out? Let
me do a refresh. My--is my audio on in the
computer? Maybe not. But what you would hear
would be sound. As I press these different
dots it generates a sound based on the color
pallet. So it's pretty cool, low to high based
on sort of the frequency of the image. Maybe
the auto data API was on mute for that particular
demo. So that's sort of setting up the Chrome
Web Store, all that, you know, billing an
app, what is an app, what does it look like,
how does it feel, how does it act, what technologies
to use. So here--here's what the Chrome Web
Store is. And before I sort of talk about
the Chrome Web Store, I want to talk about
the current problem sort of on the Web today.
You have--I don't know about you guys but
this is how my tab page looks every, you know,
afternoon after I've been at work for the
whole day. I have a couple different new sites
open. I have maybe--you see three instances
of Gmail open because I'm lost in my tabs
and maybe I've signed in to different accounts.
You know, I have new sites, I have apps, I
have Facebook open, I have TechCrunch; all
these different--these applications that we
use, Facebook, and the readers and everything.
It's different, the Web is different, much
different than it used to be. These are not
sites anymore, these are apps. People are
spending all their time in these. So the Browser
UI really hasn't sort of kept up with this
pace of innovation and thinking along these
same lines, it's not ideal for the scenario.
Same thing with permissions. So a lot of really
neat HTML5 APIs like Geolocation, Storage,
Notifications API. There's some other ones
in the pipeline, like device access will be
something that will require permission. So
it requires user interaction in order to make
this stuff work. So what you end up with,
if you have this really killer app that has
all these awesome APIs, you know, on page
load, you get four or five permissions and
it's ugly. I don't know about you guys but
that's not ideal user experience. So we can
do better. The last problem of the Chrome
Web Store--I hope in saying to solve, is that
you have all these users out there. And if
you do a search for Google.com today--I'm
putting a really cool animation. If you do
a search for Google.com today, right, you--and
you find the best photo app or something,
photo sharing app. You know, you're not necessarily
going to get the best photo sharing app out
there, Google Search is not ideal for discovering
applications on the Web. So you have all these
apps, you have all these developers, how do
you sort of connect them together for developers
to reach a new market? And of course, that's
sort of where the Chrome Web Store comes in.
So the Web Store is going to be about discoverability,
right? You should be able to find the killer
apps you want, install them on a Chrome. Or
in general, it's any browsers that you access
the store and you should be able to find those
applications. And the best ones will surface
to the top based on user ratings and reviews.
So if your app is killer, if you're a small
time developer, you know, your app can rise
to the top if you do a good job and users
like what they're seeing. It's all about distribution,
so reaching those users. Auto-update for package
apps. We'll talk about package apps in a bit
but it's the same auto-update. If any of you
went to the Chrome extensions talk earlier,
Chrome extensions, once you upload them to
the gallery and upload a new version they
are auto-updated for all users of your extension.
So the same thing will be true for packaged
apps for the Chrome Web Store. If you, you
know, hit deploy, if you hit publish to the
Web Store, your applications will get updated
for all users of your app. So that's pretty
cool. Obviously, revenue for developers is
huge. You know, you can make money off a Web
app. That's kind of a new idea, I would say.
And themes and extensions will be part of
this too. So you'll be able to sell extensions,
you will be able to sell themes as well. Themes
meaning, themes for Google Chrome.
So the whole process of publishing app on
the Web Store, you're in complete control.
So we don't do, you know, app approval or
anything like that. You pay a one time registration
fee and you're all set, you can go ahead and
publish. Unless your app does something malicious
or it's flagged by users, you know, we won't
interact, we won't intervene at all. So you
create the app, you upload it to the store
and you provide the product information. There's
things like screenshots and videos, and then
you get published, and you reach users and
sell your application. So it's very frictionless.
We have a payment system set-up with a licensing
API that you can talk to. Who's installed
my app, you know, to make sure they're valid
users for the hosted apps at least. It uses
OpenID and OAuth, so two technologies that
are open standards using RESTful API. And
we also provide things like analytics in the
store. So, you know, how many times did this
user or how many times did this user--people
have installed this application, uninstalled
it, viewed the listing page, and so on and
so forth. So, there's this been this asterisk
here on all the payment stuff for a couple
slides now, that's because when we do launch
the store later in the year, you have to have
a U.S. bank account in order to publish on
a store. So, until it's--this sort of officially
launched in Brazil, you won't have the ability
to publish an application. But you can prepare
yourself for it. And I do recommend you do
that. We'll talk about how. I just want to
mention, when we do launch, they'll be, you
know, free. You can have a free application.
You can pay to install so a user can choose
to pay a one time fee to install your application.
There'll be subscriptions both monthly and
annually. There'll be a freemium model so
you can upload a free version of apps so the
users can have a trial version. If they like
your app they can choose to install the premium
version. And then you can choose your own
adventure. So, you're not, again, locked in
to any technology or any payment solution.
You can use your own. You can even sell your
app on your own, you know, server if you wanted
to, there's no restrictions. But the, again,
the benefit of the store here is that, for
the discoverability and ease of integration.
So what can you do to prepare if you can't
sell anything. Before I do that, I want to
show you another cool example because they're
awesome. I'll make sure I have sound. Yes.
Okay, so this is also using the audio data
API. This is our--basically what they've done
is, is create a sound sampler, and I'll just
play it for you right now using a--what is
it, the D key or S key. Let me try to refresh.
Can you guys hear that? Could you turn that
up a little bit? So this is reading an MP3
file and then producing a spectrum. But what
I can do using Audio Data API I ran, I can
sample different portions. I can also read
this thing backwards if I wanted to and really
get the full effect there. But just--certainly
the capabilities of things you can do with
audio and video and multimedia HTML5, it's
pretty amazing. Okay, I'm done with the audio,
thank you. All right, so I've mentioned installation.
How do you install a Web application? In Chrome
at least, if users visit the store and see
your listing and want to, you know, purchase
your user free application, they can install
their app--your application inside of Chrome.
So this is an image of what the new tab page
will probably or might look like and this
is available in the developer channel of Chrome.
So, you can install applications. And basically
what it is it has this big icon, a launch
icon to your app so you just can access, you
know, their favorite applications really quickly.
And so there will also be a link to the store
where they can find and discover new ones.
So I mentioned the launcher. This is, you
know, an example of what an icon would look
like and the options that are available to
you. Users have the full choice to sort of
open the application regular tab in Google
Chrome. Excuse me. It can open as a pin tab
so they can actually sort of move the app
over to side by itself so it's away from the
rest of the tabs sort of to minimize that
clutter that you saw. Or they can choose to
run full screen which is kind of cool for
things like games, or hopefully not uninstall
your apps. So that's why that one's pushed
down so far. Unless there's--there's also
an option to have sort of a pop-up panel UI.
So if you have something, maybe like a count--a
calculator widget or a clock, you can run
that in a little panel pop-up. The tab and
the panel are something you can programmatically
choose. The pin tab and full screen are just
something the user has to manually select
from this list. But what this allows you to
do--so, it's got the convenient new tab page,
but it simplifies the permissions model. So
if you have an app that uses Geolocation,
Notifications and Storage, it's basically
just, you know, do you trust this application,
click to install and that's it. They don't
have to grant access to all these different
APIs separately. It's sort of at the trust
level of the store and installing application
and you hereby say that you trust the application
to do whatever it needs to do. So let's talk
about hosted apps. Hosted apps are probably
going to be, in my opinion, they're super
easy to create for the store. If you have
an existing Web site, it's literally a matter
of wrapping that existing Web site in a manifest
file. Very similar to extensions, it's actually
the same model. So if you have a Web site,
you add some metadata to it and boom you're
done. You upload to the store and you've already
created the app, right, there's nothing else
to do. But what it does is you have the--all
the permissions. So this is what, you know,
a pop-up would look like. This app, Google
Maps, running in the Web Store would require
your physical location for the Geolocation
and storage for offline access. And so, you
click to install. There's three permissions
right now, I mentioned them before. As new
APIs become available they'll be added to
the list as well. So how do you--if you have
a Web app that exists on the Web today, how
do you detect that the user has installed
this application? How do you know they're
launching it from Chrome instead of just visiting,
you know, the app from a URL or a bookmark?
And what we'll have available for you is--it's
not really an API, but it's a property. So,
Window Chrome app is installed, you can check
that. If that property exists on the Chrome
app object then you know the user's installed
the app. And then, they paid money if they
purchased it or if it's free. Otherwise, you
know, they're just visiting it as a normal
user without install. So you can display maybe
a different UI, you can display, "Would you
like to purchase this app?" or something.
So, let me just demo this and show you what
this looks like. I have taken the liberty
and spent countless hours in creating a really
nice demo application. It runs on my local
machine right now but obviously, this could
be any domain, any Web site. On the Web, we
could wrap Google.com if we want it to. We
could wrap Google Maps if we wanted to in
a hosted app. But I will show you what this
looks like in all of its glory. So the first
thing you'll notice is that this is just a,
you know, helloworld.html. And this is not
really a Web app. It's just a static page.
But it happens to use a lot of cool HTML5
APIs. This is text. This is using the fonts
API and all that good CSS stuff. But you'll
notice that the first thing when the page
loads, it wants to use Geolocation. So I get
the browser pop-up, right? This app wants
physical access to your location. So I'll
say, "Yes," because I do trust this app, I
built it. And for some reason, of course,
it's putting us in the water. That's really
interesting. So, it's probably because of
the Ethernet. Oh, fantastic. Well, we got
close to Brazil, okay. Let me try that again.
I want to see. The wireless is probably more
accurate but I assure you Geolocation does
work. So, let's say that worked. Now it's
got my location. I've granted it permission.
But this app, you know, it's, obviously, it's
not ideal but it also wants to send notifications.
So when I hit "send notification," right,
I get another dialogue. And you get the point,
right? This is kind of annoying. In order
to really experience this app I have to go
through all these hurdles. So, now that I've
obviously done that I can send notifications.
It's an HTML5 notification. This last one
is using the FileWriter API, which is a brand
new API that recently landed in Chrome, in
Chrome dev channel. So you can actually write
files and write directories and read directories
and files using Javascript. And the reason
I'm getting code exceeded error here is because
I don't have the proper permission set. Right
now in Chrome, at least for the foreseeable
near future, you have to be an application
and request the permission in your manifest
file in order to write and read files. I'll
show you the code for that just so you believe
me. So I'm not out putting random text.
So this is what the file looks. This is what
an API looks like. There's a new sort of method
on the window object. So I can request the
file system, I want temporary file access.
I'll give it a size and then I, you know,
give success and error callbacks. The success
callback will take the file system object
that's passed to that callback and it will
basically do a get file. If it finds that
file, it will try--excuse me, if it finds
that file, it will try to read it, otherwise
since I have this create "true," if it doesn't
exist I'll try to create it. In this case,
it doesn't exist on my local storage system
so I get that code exceeded error. So, my
error callback is handed--or is handled instead
of the success callback. And you can do other
things like read directories and whatnot,
but that is not the point. Last thing I wanted
to show is that I am making that check for--if
this app is installed using the easy install
parameter. So you can sell the message here.
You know, this launch, this was normally--this
app was launched via bookmarker or link so
I just navigated to this page. Okay, so that's
a normal web app, I've already built that.
Let's see what this looks like as installable
hosted application. So the first thing you're
going to do is create a manifest.json file.
So the exact same process as creating an extension.
You give a name, you know, description of
your app, you have logos. There's various
logos you can provide for the store, there's
one for the launcher icon, there's one for
fab icon, there's one for, you know, the listing
in the store itself. So you have a lot of
flexibility and options there. But the new
property for the store itself is this app
object, this app JSON object. And the first
property in there is the launch URL. The launch
URL is the URL of your application. So if
I was to just package this app, this app that
I created, you know, in 10 minutes for the
Web Store, this is all I would need to do.
I would just need to write, you know, these
10 lines of JSON, package that up, upload
it to the store and boom, I'm done. But if
users are using Chrome they can obviously
have a better experience. So the first thing
optionally that we can do, I mentioned that
you can launch in different modes. You can
launch as panel app, you can give it a size
and a width. By default, it's tabs so we'll
just leave that out. But I mentioned permission.
So again, just like the extensions there's
different permission bits that you can set.
My app is going to have Geolocation unlimited
storage for FileWriter and also notifications.
So I can set those inside the manifest file
so I can say this app will need these permissions.
And those permissions will apply to any URLs
that I list in the URLs array under the app
object. So any URLs basically get the white-listing
of these permissions. If you're not within
this list then you don't have unlimited storage
notifications for Geolocation. So to show
you this in action, I will close this. I could
keep it open, but I'll close it. Using the
Chrome extensions API, I will navigate to
my app. So I'm just basically uploading or
loading up an unpackaged application. It's
got all my files in there. You know, there's
a helloworld.html, there's a HTML file for
the notification and there's the manifest
file. I'll click select and actually, it's
already here so it didn't do anything. But
I'll enable that application. And so, the
first thing you notice is my first app is
available now in my new tab page. So I can
choose to launch this in different modes,
or I can just see what this looks like when
I launch it. So, you notice a couple of things.
Just to prove that this does work, I will
refresh this page. I just got rid of the Geolocation
permission. I said I don't want to access
the Geolocation anymore, but since I'm a Web
app now, since I'm an install-hosted app,
it's automatically got the Geolocation. I
can send notifications without a permission
setting to pop-up. There it is. And you see
a new message here. You see log file created
so the file system API is actually working
now. We can create files because we have that
permission set. And obviously, at the bottom
there, you know, we're making the check to
see if we're installed via the app store using
the Chrome Web Store and indeed, we are. So,
a better user experience but very trivial.
I added three permissions to this web app
to make it a better experience for all users.
It's just fantastic.
So that was hosted apps. But there's another
type of app called a packaged app. And packaged
apps are very similar to Chrome extensions.
In fact, they basically are glorified Chrome
extensions. So you have a normal Web site
but you add some extra metadata and you wrap
it up in a CRX file, which is basically a
zip file. It supports auto-updating so, again,
when you upload a new version in the store,
all your users are auto-updated. So, when
would you use this over hosted web application?
Well, there's a couple of reasons. So if you
don't require a server for one. If you just
want to package up a Flash game for instance,
a SWF file, you can absolutely do that. And
you don't want to--or you don't have a server
component that you want to talk to or host
that application anywhere. You can just choose
it, choose to upload it to the Web Store and
boom, it's there, and then people can download
it from there. There's tighter integration
with Chrome so we'll talk about some of the
APIs that are available to the packaged apps.
And they have elevated permissions because
they're packaged. They're installed in Chrome
whereas a Web app doesn't have that same liberty.
And lastly, if you don't care about supporting
other browsers, I mean, that's fine. You know,
if you want to just start at Chrome, that's
totally cool. It's just like an extension.
It will only be run in Chrome so you don't
have to worry about sort of developing for
all these different browsers. But there's
more things you can do with in a packaged
app. So you have full access to all the extensions
APIs, except browser action and page action.
How many people went to the extensions talk
by the way? A few people? Okay. So page action
and browser actions are the little icons that
appear when you install a Chrome extensions
in the top right corner of the browser that
do interaction. Again, you can do things like
content scripts and background pages. Content
scripts inject the Javascript or CSS onto
a page based on a set of rules that you specify.
Background pages are great for things like
polling. You can do cross-domain XHR request,
which is pretty cool, in background pages.
Obviously, that's not something a normal web
application can do because of the restrictions.
But there's really much, much more. So you
can write a packaged, you know, Web app for
the Chrome Web Store that does things with
context menus. So you can modify the right
click menu and add your options there. Tab
and window manipulation, Omnibar, you can
tie into the Chrome's URL bar with your own
API, it provides search results or do what
ever you want there. History, bookmarks and
cookies, these are thing that, at least bookmarks
and history, that, you know, normal Web app
can't do but a Chrome extension has a permission.
So that's sort of an overview of the Web Store.
And I've mentioned, you know, you heard a
lot about--you heard a lot of preaching about
HTML5 today. And a lot of people think it's
not ready, there's been some posts recently.
I would say it is ready and it's definitely
ready to experiment with at the very least.
Here's a picture of 2008, the browser support
in 2008, for various APIs. So you have Geolocation,
forms, you know, Web Workers. It's very sparse.
So this is two years ago. One year ago, we're
getting a lot better. So, you know, Chrome2
comes along. It's got most support here. Firefox
is catching up, IE is still kind of lagging
behind. But by 2010, you just can see this
graph really starting to fill out, right?
So most WebKit browsers have pretty much everything
implemented. You know, Firefox4 is there.
I guess you did, wow, cool. So you edited
IE9. So IE9 is doing a fantastic job with
a lot of these APIs, video, audio for example,
SVG. So you can imagine in a year, you know,
where this is going to be. It's just absolutely
ridiculous how fast the innovation is happening.
Time for an awesome demo. So you saw--you've
seen the device orientation API a lot today.
Here is another example of, you know, using
an interactive game. So I can speed this up
if I tilt it forward. Anyway, I have three
lives so hopefully it would be fast because
this is the best I've ever done, promise.
I'll try something tricky. [MAKES NOISE] But
now this is--now that this stuff is all native
to the browser, right, you really have different
interactions with applications then ever before.
I will just kill myself, no? Well, you get
the point. There we go. Seven twenty-seven,
it's not too bad. So here is the current browser
share as of September 2010. And just soaked
this in for a little bit. This is sort of
the state right now. You know, it's not September
anymore so the numbers have change a little
bit. But in general, you get the idea. Modern
browsers are taking up, you know, a good chunk
of that. But for the most part, people running
IE6, 7 and 8. Which is fine but the problem
is you can't leverage these cool APIs and
target those browsers, it's just impossible.
So what you do as a developer is you have
to hack around things, right? This is the
Acid3 test rendered by Chrome. And here's
what it looks like rendered by IE6, I believe.
So again, between thes two different versions,
say this is the layout and color scheme of
your site, you know, you have all cool CSS
tricks and then--but other users are seeing
this, that's not ideal, they get the score
of 20 out of 100. So products like Google
Wave for instance, just as an example, did
something, you know, they choose not to support
IE6 anymore because the development cost is
way too much. You end up having to have JavaScript
hacks and, you know, spending way more time
than you need to working around these issues.
So Wave chose to do is have a prompt. So if
you're in one of these--if you're in Internet
Explorer let's just not support you at all.
We have too many, you know, awesome capabilities
that you can access. So go ahead and install
Google Chrome Frame and Google Chrome Frame
is a plug-in. If--we probably talked about
this way too much today, but that's because
a lot of people don't know about it, unfortunately.
Google Chrome Frame is a plug-in that users
install for IE. And basically what it does
is if you imagine the browser of IE6, for
example, I think it's not IE6 but this is
the image I found, the user installs the plug-in
and the entire rendering portion. So anything
in the tab, the actual Web page itself, is
all rendered with a Chrome rendering engine.
So you get things like CSS3, you get things
like Geo location. All the stuff that's not
in that older browser, you get for free. You
also get speed and performance. You get the
security and sandbox of Google Chrome, which
is one of the best in my opinions. And it's
auto-updated along with Chrome, so they get
the latest and greatest when the plug-in,
the new plug in is pushed. And that includes
things like the--integrated Flash in the PDF
or inside of Chrome. So also open source so
you can go check out the code if you want.
As a developer, it really literally couldn't
be any easier to put this thing with inside
of your app, with inside of your site. So
if you are writing a hosted app and you want
other users, not just Chrome users, you know,
IE6 users for example, to access these APIs
in your Web app to its full potential, all
you have to do is include a meta tag on your
HTML page using the chrome=1 for the content.
Or if you can't, you know, add that to every
page you can send a header with the same value
there. Super simple. The only problem with
this is that the user has to have the plug-in
installed. So if they don't then there's no
benefit there. But there's zero cost you as
a developer. So that was sort of a high level
overview of the Chrome Web Store. I just want
to mention that, you know, we talked--I showed
you an application, sort of how do you package
it for a hosted app, talked a little bit about
package apps. But the building an app for
the store is your choice, right? There's no
limitation on technology whatsoever. You can
choose one from the Web stack, you know, the
open Web stack platform. But you can write
a Flash game. You can use a Silverlight, the
plug in. You can do things like native client,
which is running C++ in the browser. That's
a Chrome-specific thing but again, it's your
choice of technology. So anything you want,
a LAMP stack, you know, choose your own adventure
if you will. So I think the takeaways here
are that the Web is innovating, right? We're
seeing things like you saw it all today, HTML,
JS and hardware acceleration. There's literally
a parity with the desktop now. And I guarantee
you within six months to a year, you're going
to have things like device integration. So
you can access the microphone, and USB drives,
and all that great stuff, camera, for instance,
using the webcam. So don't wait until 2022
that--that's I think what the W3C said when
the HTML5 will finally be ready. I assure
you it's out there and living well. And I
think with the pace of innovation that's happening
right now were really seeing that in action.
Features are first class citizens. You know,
things like video and audio we take for granted
with Flash and in other plug-ins. But now
we've the ability to do these and manipulate
them using JavaScript inside of the--in the
native platform. The Chrome Web Store is a
great way to monetize your applications, your
existing application. Or create entirely a
new one, right? And if users are visiting
the Web Store in Chrome and they choose to
install the app then they have a little bit
better experiences if you, you know, set up
the manifest file correctly. And you can finally
monetize an application on the Web, which
is pretty exciting. So your HTML5 investment
will be rewarded. A couple of essential links.
You know, here's the documentation links for
Web Store, for Web apps in relation to Web
Store extensions. But do stay in touch. You
can follow us in Twitter. Our developer operations
team is @ChromiumDev. We tweet a bunch of
great stuff there. You can ask questions in
both of these forms, one is for--dedicated
to HTML5 questions and one is dedicated for
Chromium apps, Chrome apps. But also file
bugs. If you find issues, that's the only
way we know about this stuff. And you, as
developers, you know, really, we know we listen
to you guys. Lastly, here's the feedback link,
mgddbr, if you'd like to give me feedback.
So I'll take Q&A now and I thank you for your
time.